[Music]
wolf of wallstreet the love of the movie
the scene I mean I was I had to I had to
just imagine when I was watching the
movie there's so many orgy scenes party
scenes there's so much nudity I thought
maybe a fun film to shoot fun movie to
people what's it like to shoot those
scenes when there's a scene where your
character is on a plane filled with
naked women is their party it was I mean
look it's it's it's Martin Scorsese you
know that's that's a it's a dream come
true and the thing about his set is you
know everybody who's there is the best
the best of what they do and everybody's
so passionate excited to be there and
you know the woman who plays waitress
number four is leaving set to go to a
Broadway show there's just so much
talent there and I think that's why
there's so much creativity just you know
he's the best and I think that also that
also is true for the people who come in
to get buck-ass naked and simulate sex
and the orgy scenes like these people
are awesome at doing that and and I
remember in that sense funny I did not
get a call
there's one girl who I remember in that
specific scene that you brought up on
the plane and the plane suddenly has to
be put aside and I ever ever at least
naked people go flying see and she drove
up from Tennessee that morning to be in
that scene and we were all grouped
together doing you know whatever it is
you do in an orgy scene you know and
we're doing our thing and all of a
sudden he that would be crying sorry
sorry sorry sorry
but when the turbulence hit and we all
sort of shifted to the right one of the
plane seats went up in the air and
landed on this poor girl's foot oh and
you know before anybody could tend to
her she just without missing a beat she
was like I'm gonna tell you right now
you can cut this foot off but I'm gonna
be in this orgy she was some orgy look
at that one foot lady over there